eu queria inicialmente é começar falando
para vocês que realmente eu não tenho
filhos autistas eu tenho filhos que
estão é denominados como típicos né
mas eu tenho imensos filhos adotivos
autistas por aí em 2009 que eu recebi
esse apelido de encantadora de autistas
quando me formei em pacientes com
necessidades especiais
em 2003 eu comecei a receber uma
quantidade muito grande de pacientes no
espectro do autismo e eu percebi que eu
não sabia como atender sem ser dentro
das características de indicação na
odontologia
então se nós fomos buscar artigos na
odontologia sobre o atendimento do
paciente no espectro autista do autismo
não tem é muito difícil e uma das
indicações é o uso da contenção física
a contenção física ela pode ser desde um
abraço dos pais até mesmo artifícios que
você contem com faixas de velcro a
contenção ela não é contra indicada no
tratamento odontológico ela tem
indicação sim mas eu vi aqui a maioria
dos pacientes que eu atendia eu tinha
que usar a contenção física não era isso
que eu queria então fui pesquisar em
outras áreas que não da odontologia que
essa era a indicação principalmente para
otimista adulto de baixo funcionamento e
fui pesquisar falei não não é assim que
eu quero quero tentar melhorar isso
e nesses anos então de pesquisa eu
comecei a usar técnicas de abordagem
lúdica e mudar o foco e tentar pesquisar
é ver como eu podia me comunicar com
essa pessoa
uma das coisas iniciais foi é que o
dentista assim a gente naquela correria
do dia a dia você percebe que você não
tem muito tempo para se dedicar à aquele
paciente eu percebi que eu tinha que
individualizar cada atendimento que cada
um era um
ele era único então tinha que colheu
informações daquele indivíduo e preparar
a sessão para aquele atendimento
uma das coisas principais então era eu
perder ou ganhar tempo em buscar o
contato visual que prudente está é uma
coisa que a gente acaba foi na cadeira e
é o próximo é o próximo é o próximo ea
gente não individualiza então atendendo
os especiais desde 2003 desde 2003 o
estudo autismo já tinha adaptado várias
formas de comunicação que acabei indo
buscar no que as foram suzano que as
psicólogas usam então eu adaptei opex a
comunicação por troca de figuras para a
odontologia
então eu tenho que buscar uma
comunicação com esse paciente adaptei
pra ele pra quê para que ele entendesse
o que vai ter pra hoje o que vai ser o
que vai ser feito nele daquele
consultório então a gente vai se
comunicar e tentar sua comunicação e
apresentar o tratamento
em 2009 tive o prazer de conhecer esse
menino idris
ele procurou a uma clínica escola onde
eu trabalhava que eu dava aula nesse
lugar e ele veio para o tratamento era
uma criança bastante agitada na época
hoje ele está um menino bem mais mais
controlado e aí os dois alunos que
estavam 100 pacientes foram selecionados
para ir até a sala de espera e buscar o
idris para o atendimento
quando chegou na recepção ele estava um
pouco agitado ele estava bagunçando um
pouco tudo os meninos voltaram correndo
ea expressão deles eles falaram assim
professora não esse não dá outra não
quero isso não porque ele está
aguardando nas paredes ele não quer
entrar ele tá batendo tudo está
quebrando tudo dá outro que esse não vai
dar
aí eu falei não não é assim nós vamos
atender meninos vamos ver como vai ser
então fui até a recepção conhecer a mãe
que até entre vocês aquele e e fui
conhecer um pouco da vida desse menino
inicialmente ela falou que ele gostava
muito de 3 e naquele momento não tinha
preparado nenhum material pra que eu
pudesse abordar ele de uma maneira
melhor
mas mostrei a pasta de comunicação que
havia criado com figuras mostrando todo
o tratamento odontológico e todas as
fases e aí ele foi acalmando ele foi
pressionado a vencer
então ele foi olhando nos meus olhos nos
sentamos no chão e ele foi conhecendo um
pouquinho do que ia ser eu fui
antecipando que acontecer
como naquele momento não estava
preparada para isso então na sessão
seguinte eu fui pra casa e falei esse
menino tem que entrar espontâneo porque
assim eu quero que seja o tratamento
então peguei um trem que eu tinha do meu
filho pois uma cordinha levei pra
clínica e falei vamos tentar
fiquei andando na recepção da clínica
puxando esse trem de um lado para o
outro e o inter seguiu ele entrou
espontâneo na clínica
então pra mim já era um passo porque a
partir do momento que ele faz uma coisa
espontânea é muito mais fácil que ele vá
repetir essa só no futuro
e aí ele entrou a partir do momento que
ele entrou então ele se deparou com
diversos dentistas fantasiados de
dentistas
então é aquela coisa que ninguém gosta
de encontrar com dentista fantasiado
tava todo mundo se luva de máscaras e
óculos e vestido de branco
naquele momento ele já se jogou no chão
começou a balançar o tronco e tava muito
difícil a comunicação de novo então tive
que sentar no chão conversar com ele
tentar voltar a manter um foco de
comunicação e com essa foto que eu sou a
única a dentista que eu tenho prêmio
orgulho autista brasil e tem muito
orgulho desse desse prêmio
aos poucos ele foi aceitando a
manipulação a manipulação da boca o
toque foi conhecendo a luva máscara
óculos e nós fomos montando um dentista
para ele
hoje ele consegue ser atendido ainda ele
conheceu a cadeira odontológica a gente
brincando de sentar-se corretas sentar
escorrega brincamos escorregador
ele conheceu a cadeira embora o
atendimento dele ainda seja no chão ao
lado da cadeira que é onde ele se sente
mais conforto mas pra mim não importa a
atender no chão no sofá na cama aonde
for
o que importa eu devolver saúde bucal e
proporcionar saúde bucal para essa
pessoa
é a parte lúdica a gente na odontologia
usa muito na pediatria e às vezes quando
nós até nos deparamos com pacientes
especiais adultos às vezes a gente não
sabe muito o como fazer e eu percebi
nesses anos que a gente consegue sim
usar a abordagem lúdica e tentará
comunicação e é assim que eu tenho feito
todos esses anos
quando eu fiz o meu mestrado eu fiz o
mestrado adaptando o pecs para
odontologia
então eu tenho toda uma parafernália no
consultório de adaptação de material
estruturado para isso
só que quando eu vou tentar convencer o
meu colega dentista a atender um
paciente no espectro do autismo e falar
mas eu vou perder tempo e fazer tudo
isso
então agora eu tô fazendo doutorado e eu
tô eu adaptei todo esse material para um
programa de computador
então nós vamos ter as fases do
tratamento odontológico disponibilizados
no computador e essa mãe vai poder fazer
o download em casa ela vai antecipar o
que vai acontecer no consultório e vai
facilitar o entendimento dessa criança
do que ele vai passar lá no consultório
para os dentistas a mesma coisa ele vai
poder ter o programa vai facilitar a
comunicação e o que tem de importante é
como um trabalho de doutorado eu fiz uma
parceria essa distribuição será gratuita
sim para todos que quiserem é baixar
pela internet isso eu acredito que com o
tempo vai facilitar a gente conseguir
dentistas que queiram tentar e mães que
comece inicialmente precocemente a levar
seus filhos ao consultório eu falo que
eu sou uma militante na causa do autismo
embora não tenha ninguém é no espectro
do autismo na minha família mas eu tenho
dois problemas grandes que enfrente nas
palestras ou seja eu tenho que convencer
as mães que nós dentistas não somos
nenhum monstro que pode levar que nós
não vamos judiar de nenhuma criança e
que a prevenção tem que começar cedo
porque se você não começar cedo levar o
seu filho dentes fazer a prevenção não
tem como não atenderam à contenção
física
nós vamos ter
chegar à contenção ou ter que mandar
para anestesia geral
a gente tem que fazer a prevenção tem
que começar precocemente em relação à
contenção física às vezes têm mais fala
nossa isso é um horror como eu posso
conter mas eu vou contar um caso de
consultório para vocês há pouco tempo
ver uma mãe ao consultório o menino
estava com muita dor de dente 16 anos
ele estava com muita dor ele estava
quebrando tudo ele estava batendo a
cabeça na parede ele veio com hematoma
no rosto de tanto que ele se batia ea
gente tentou uma internação serviço
público não conseguiu essa mãe não tinha
condições de pagar nada particular
ele ficou três meses com dor porque ela
não aceitava que o que usar essa
contenção física e eu não tinha
condições de fazer o procedimento sem
conter depois de três meses eu já não
tava dormindo mais eu liguei pra ela fez
abel deixa aconteceu filho deixa eu
fazer
aí ela autorizou eo consultório naquele
momento eu faço sempre a cirurgia com
meu marido que é pouco maxilo e nós
estávamos lá esperando o bruno chegar ea
mãe chegou chorando com um terço na mão
e ficou na porta chorando o tempo
inteiro segurando aquele terço
só que pra colocar a contenção física
também têm formas lúdicas por mais que
seja estranho de falar isso pra vocês
têm formas de colocar vamos conversando
brincando e o bruno estava inteirinho
contido na cadeira anestesiamos então
mantive a boca dele apertam tinha que
fazer extração do dente do dente que ele
estava com dor
o marcelo fez a extração por ser buco
maxilo a experiência dele em cirurgia
ele é muito mais rápido do que eu para
esse procedimento então fui mantendo o
condicionamento mantendo a atenção do
bruno ele fez futuro ou assim que
terminou
estávamos voltando bruno ele pulou da
cadeira ele não fala mas ele gritou e
abraçou e beijou o marcelo porque a
marcelo chorou e todo mundo chorou e aí
foi um problema porque que aconteceu
isso ele estava anestesiado ea dor de
tantos meses havia passado
na semana seguinte ele tinha mais um
dente para tirar
aí eu não quis arriscar fazer solto para
saber vamos agendar e ele vem a esse
momento ela deixou que o filmasse
mas eu não trouxe filme é muito extenso
para passar pra vocês
foi a mesma coisa aceito a contenção
muito bem fizemos a extração muito
melhor do que no primeiro dia porque ele
já sabia que ele não tinha sofrido
naquele momento eu falei isabel próxima
consulta vamos fazer esse menino souto
conversei com ele bruno próxima vez não
tem contenção vai ser tudo a mesma coisa
confia
ele veio quando foi sentar na cadeira
ele ficou meio sem sentar porque não
tinha um estabilizador lá ele pode
sentar vai ser assim é solto e assim foi
e desde janeiro esse menino é tratado
solto no consultório ele fica super
tranquilo ele aceita o tratamento e ele
aprendeu que a gente é consegue sim é
devolver saúde bucal de uma maneira que
precisa entender o tratamento
odontológico é preciso que precisava
naquele momento e ele ficou livre da dor
hoje eu acredito que esse menino nunca
mais vai precisar da contenção mas se a
gente voltasse a um tempo maior atrás
talvez tivesse sido feito uma prevenção
abordagem lúdica com essa criança com
quatro anos três anos de idade e dois
anos de idade
uma que ele não ia chegar até uma cara
tão extensa como ele teve teve que a
perda do dente outra que ele nunca ia
precisar passar pela contenção foi uma
experiência pra todo mundo então o que
eu quero falar pra vocês é a contenção
ela também não tem um ato tão ruim para
a gente ela serve de condicionamento do
caso que precisa também em relação aos
meus colegas dentistas é onde o pêlo
mais porque eu luto e falou muito para
eles vamos tentar
vamos tentar porque pra mim nenhuma mãe
aqui eu tenho diversas mães que são mães
de pacientes meus para nenhum deles eu
nunca falei eu vou tratar eu vou
conseguir
eu sempre falo eu vou tentar porque eu
preciso ver primeiro se ele vai gostar
daquele consultório se ele vai me
aceitar como dentista se ele vai aceitar
o tratamento lá porque às vezes um
cheiro uma cor alguma coisa acaba o
vínculo e às vezes o dentista que tem na
esquina da casa dele que não é
especialista que não têm curso não tem
nada ele é cria algum vínculo com aquele
profissional e é lá que o negócio vai
acontecer
o que eu tenho pra falar pra vocês então
em relação ao doutor logia que eu acho
que é brincando sim que se atende e essa
história de encantadora de autistas é é
mentira realmente eles é que me encantam
e o luto por isso trabalho por isso e
comentou com vários pacientes meus e
mães né que realmente eu não não
trocaria a vida que eu levo atendendo
pacientes autistas todos os dias para me
dedicar talvez até por crianças típicas
birrentas que tem por aí então é isso